NASA announcing another major milestone
overnight for its historic Mars Lander
the solar panels on the insight
spacecraft opened without a hitch like
in this animation after the lander
touchdown insight can now recharge its
own batteries this newly released photo
shows insight in the Martian landscape
Jamie yuccas is in the control room at
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory in
Pasadena California a lot of people were
cheering yesterday and brightly so good
morning this is the place where tensions
were highest on Monday as insight
traveled through Mars's atmosphere to a
safe landing so far the billion-dollar
project has paid off nASA says the
lander will teach us about the red
planet mapping a course for future even
more ambitious missions touchdown
confirmed the celebrations inside the
Jet Propulsion lab control room were
echoed at watch parties across the
country from New York's Times Square to
Texas to Los Angeles in six-and-a-half
make-or-break minutes insight entered
the Martian atmosphere at more than
12,000 miles per hour heating to some
2,700 degrees before softly touching
down and sending back its first photo to
see that that payoff finally happened
for every one of them it's amazing you
can't get a better feeling than that do
you get a couple days of rest now or
what hello there's no breasts there's no
rest at all in the coming days
scientists will use insights cameras to
find the best locations to place the
spacecraft's main tools a seismometer to
measure the planet's internal activity
and a heat probe to take its temperature
what role will insight play in humans
getting tomorrow's insight is going to
give us visibility into asteroid impacts
on Mars
so we'll know when it's safe to go to
Mars and we're on Mars our astronauts
should go to be safe
NASA is just one player in this new
space race SpaceX is among a number of
companies hoping to launch manned
missions to Mars founder Elon Musk plans
a cargo mission by 2022 followed by a
man Mars space flight two years later
whatever you want to
achieve here is to make Mars seem
possible make it seem as though it's
something that we can do in our
lifetimes must timeline is more
ambitious than NASA's which wants to
send humans to Mars by the 2030s nASA
says humans would have to live on the
red planet for two years the time it
takes the planets to align for a return
that's why they want to use the moon
first as a proving ground before sending
anyone to Mars
Gale alright Jamie yuccas reporting
thank you very much you know what's so
cool about that story in addition to the
success of it all is to see the NASA
engineers because normally you think of
them as very up to and buttoned-up
people a couple I've met have been
uptight and buttoned up but it shows
that they have a great sense of humor
and really take pride and joy in their
work I love a little dancing in the
handshake my work paying off yeah when
you look at how hard it was to get it
there you can see why they were did you
know jumping out of their seats success
a good thing